I look like Helga from here today we're
gonna be trying the squiggle brow I have
heard of the squiggle brow I've also
heard of the squiggle lip people just
really like squiggly things right now no
one's actually doing this for real like
you're not stepping out into the world
like this I can't even read that it's a
well-made brow like an ocean over the
top of your eyes
I do fill in my brows I generally just
don't do makeup in general it's better
than the feather brow for sure I only
want a swig Alette the end and I think
what I'm gonna do is just like dip into
my natural brow and start the squiggle
process so in terms of confidence right
now I'm out of solid four cup can I just
cover my entire brow with concealer
swing-away - squiggle with it okay need
a pencil I'm using is called corrupt and
I am corrupt in my face rate I'm drying
my squiggle if I'm going big I'm going
to hop wait that's my house there you go
don't do concealer first I think I had
more like zigzag but maybe that's gonna
be the new trend after this the zigzag
brow this squiggle is about to be off
the [ __ ] chain do you think
people are gonna react positive for
they're gonna send me home we're looking
at oop it looks like I have little
toupee is floating over my eyes
Art's defined Wow
I think it's time for us to show these
looks off you know interesting yeah it's
better than what I've seen on the
internet okay in the sights
I'm worried why you're covering your
face though this one's just thick I
would pass on the the squid said
squiggle brow yours looks like something
wrong I'm one Browdy today I still don't
see a squiggle we're walking down the
street different good different bad I
want to do some crazy [ __ ] with your
eyebrows you should come to New York
like does anyone feel super cool here
I'd say the reactions have been a more
positive for Sasha I learned that you
shouldn't use a grey eyeliner pencil to
fill in your eyebrows no one's gonna
insult us to our faces I don't think
let's roll the camera back looks like
you're going to church the responses
that we've gotten around the office I
love he look cute I would do the
squiggle brow for maybe Halloween a rave
I get the squiggle bro thumbs up if you
do it right the thing to learn here is
subtlety my look a little over at the
top so I'm all for the idea great idea
horrible execution squiggle brow like up
in the club with the LED eyelashes what
clubs are you going to I'm not a
professional but I wanted to you know
try it to show the other people out
there who don't do their own makeup but
they also shouldn't do it and they
should have somebody with them who knows
how to do their brows help them you know
you'll get better results as opposed to
this
[Music]